quando è talmente tante cose da fare che
inizi a mischiare la vita con youtube è
un placement anche perché sarei facendo
un placement del latte in generale
quindi tipo alle mucche neo placement
oppure di parlare di youtube di come si
sono evolute le cose sono super
orgoglioso però alle volte faccio cose
che preferirei non fare ad esempio per
le riprese del film di recente mi stanno
facendo fare cose un po strane tipo
questa ciao ragazzi buongiorno siamo a
casa mia e stiamo facendo
sono sette di social dream stiamo
facendo una cosa molto divertente che è
mettermi un treppiede gigantesco nel mio
non ciò che mi farò la ripresa in terza
persona visto sempre chiesto come fanno
quelli di film far vedere che si muovono
in terza persona treppiede
detto questo ragazzi credo abbiate visto
ormai tutti la reaction che ho fatto
l'altro giorno a gianpi
comunque sia il mio phone per chi non
l'avesse ancora capito questo tempi ma
poi lo rovescio e che poi è il latte non
ed è proprio per chi non avesse visto il
video in questione il cliente era una
sorta di leasing ironico sul mio phone
con di gianpi tech e il mio e leona
reaction dissing ironica su gianpi te
che fare reaction ironica sul vabbè
ormai credo sapete tutti cosa sia il mio
fondo a questo punto visto che lo fa
anche mia nonna
nel caso non sapesse di cosa stiamo
parlando per il mio fan vi lascio il
link in descrizione per le info siccome
è nata non è vero nel natale manca un
mese per opere jacopo e natale un mese
prima
jacopo e il bambino che appare ogni
tanto nei miei video ho deciso di
regalargli il mio von mio tap tutti e
due gli ho regalato e ho registrato la
reaction perché voi non sapete quando
regalo qualcosa a jacopo quanto è felice
e vi lascio al video perché secondo me
merita la vita
abbiamo appena descritto lato il mio tab
che per qualche mamma mia quanto buio
qua dentro
abbiamo appena di scatola toe il mio tab
il mio von li stiamo per regalare a
jacopo che ancora non è arrivato ma
rivela tra pochissimo questa cosa la
riprendo perché la reaction che in
genere a jacopo quando gli regaliamo
qualcosa è veramente preziosa cioè non
mai visto un bambino così felice quando
i regali qualcosa poteva essere lì a
koper mio manager non edizione invece li
sto rimbambito qui è vero o è là che di
qua visto come sai non vuoi un regalo ma
jacopo in un viaggio tanti regali allora
glielo diamo
poi chiudi gli occhi io controllo che tu
abbia gli occhi chiusi quante di touch o
un no ma tu ce l'hai un telefono non hai
delle amo davvero ma ti piaci nei
telefoni al telefono
e allora mai e resta paranà fino al
nostro scherzando ti ho regalato un
telefono questo aspetto
questo è un telefono parte che in questo
comunque il mio forza e del tuo il tuo
sono adesso succedere sempre mio
completo ho capito perché ci sono io
questo è è un telefono veloce e 4g
se ci giga di memoria ok poi c'è un quad
core un quad core questo ci piace quello
che poi lo schermo 5 pollici hd ips
mazzo al google play cosa facciamo
entrare la paolina tipo le veline
e c'è un'altra scatola chiusa vi
regaliamo anche il tacco mazza profitti
all'insieme qualche giorno e oggi che
mette siamo apple del natale a dicembre
si è quindi no questi erano tagliate
adesso sto scherzando
questo è il costo è mio ok adesso deve
fare anche mio tarlo che si faceva tutte
e due con di natale più grosso aspetta
prima top
so già che cover sceglierai wireless ha
come core efficaci come comunque esame
tale 16 gb di memoria cioè 300 up dove
provare tutte le 308 tutte le proprie
parole insieme allora ci si calcola
jacopo che avendo 16gb puoi fare
veramente un sacco di video un sacco di
memoria anche la prima cosa che ti
faccio vedere questa esatta notato
subito ce la può fare i geni questo tu
apri esco io
perché questa sentire però questo è un
video esclusivo non posso far vedere che
sono sì spoiler ali quindi luglio tornò
poi leo guardi poi a caso questi sono un
miliardo di applicazioni ce ne sono 300
scegline uno die che la facciamo insieme
delle pin les pins le pinze quello che
faccio la parola che facciamo tonton
offerta non è non ci assomiglia un
pochettino perché facciamo un cell t
visto che c'è la camera ogni camera va
beh siamo usciti bene
sì ma io volevo farti vedere a pezzi le
cose tuttocchi tutto va bene allora te
lo faccio vedere adesso questo qua ci
metti che fai
il bastone del sesso che adesso non ci
sto a spiegare bene perché quello di
questi fischi sa
e poi poi usare anche per i video jacopo
è poi fatti video quindi tu vai in giro
e file audio non ebbe seguito
questo se ti viene da un momento no non
so che cosa avete portato anche lo zio
toni ma io ho saputo che tu avevi
chiesto a babbo natale questo ragazzino
simili francesco gusto
vai nel video prima quasi perfetto sta
meglio meglio più empatia che lo ha
spiegato ragazzi ce l'ha come base
proprio siccome io devo chiudere anche
questo video a quello di parigi
bravissimo a metà celare anche ai vari
social che come perché ogni adolescente
se non siete iscritti e non ci vediamo
adesso la chiusa delle chiuse ha chiuso
delle chiuse con telecomandino però non
eccolo quindi adesso tu mai dato né
schiacci quello in mezzo ok
vai dai cori dei ragazzi